I made some jokes probably we're kind of
stupid buddha's arm around me at one
point and I was like oh the very
attractive human being I'm a little
nervous
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm Kelsey I am currently single and
my occupation is a video producer for
BuzzFeed specifically making video game
content I also stream on Twitch I
normally describe myself as energetic
bubbly and fun that sounds like kind of
ideas I think I'm pretty easy to get
along with I'm very good at entertaining
myself so I don't expect like other
people to kind of like be responsible
for my happiness oh my gosh being
signals great I make my own schedule I
don't have to ask other people like what
are you doing what do you want to do no
I go to all the events and I invite
whoever I'm gonna have the most fun with
I think it's just single because I've
been prioritizing work dating apps I
really like us as convenient as they are
it is very hit-or-miss I want to be in a
relationship that like makes sense and
like that we fit into each other's lives
really well my perfect first day is like
I really like going on activities like
things that we can kind of like if
you're like nervous there's something to
do and something to experience to talk
about the best date is when you have
that but then you end up just talking
the whole time and you don't even need
it if I was gonna trust anyone to find
me somebody I would definitely trust
Joyce I'm excited to find out who Joyce
is chosen for me and I'm also very
nervous I don't know I'll see everyone
has been in my DM saying help your
homegirl Kelsey Kelsey find a bag I've
gotten to a point in my life where I'm
not just gonna date to date like I want
actually someone that I really connect
with and really see when it comes to the
hustle just remember that at the end of
the day your heart matters too
I really feel like we found some really
great options for you so I'm excited to
talk to you about it so this is Tarun
he definitely works out yep he's
definitely going to like you know pick
you up put you on the motorcycle and you
know you're gonna just eat well and be
healthy yeah I mean wow he is what's
that I see some some anime helos
Dragonball Z I think he's actually like
a nerdy pick on hey he's a gamer and he
gets Brandi it looks like he might be a
teacher actually so Tehran is good
Gucci we love that for you next is
Timothy okay good he says I'm super
picky with dating people I usually don't
mind most I don't find most people
interesting I want to try to be more
open and give people a chance sounds
kind of like a hustler like I said I'm
not trying to find you a husband trying
to find you next we have mr. Joseph well
first off I hate to say about choices my
dad's name could you imagine I could
never do like Oh Joseph and he says I've
been unlucky in dating I want to find
someone beautiful inside and out Oh and
it seems like la doesn't have it when it
comes to people saying it's really hard
to find someone in LA I always think are
you not opening yourself up to it me too
I think I'm afraid like that is one
thing I had to feel from yeah we can get
like getting hurt for a couple times
next is you know always gotta hit you
with that coworker
um Blake okay you know he works with the
web scouts team yeah we've heard that
before uh yeah she works upstairs okay
he's one of Q's best friends oh that's
in Korea
yeah
cool seems cool southern boy I do like a
southern guy so which one's stood out to
you and which ones are you more excited
about I think I mean off the bat if
you've got like a nerdy quality to you
that's definitely gonna be a standout
for me that's a big thing that like it's
a part of my life that I find attractive
and other people um but I also like
people that are just a lot of fun or
people who are willing to be goofy with
me so I trust to you and I guess Jared
with this judge right okay Jared oh dear
we are attached at the hip so honestly
her boo has to be cool with me that's
why I had to be cool with him yeah yeah
so first up it's Tehran Tehran oh my god
what a big butt a big man I love like I
love like a dainty woman in a an
honestly vice versa yeah
look he does squats he's healthy she's
okay unless an Amana wait and he's a
nerd and he's a nerd any of the switch
we Annie streams mm-hmm you found honey
oh and he's verified next we have you
know I went somewhat jimothy Kim yeah a
little bit more classically classically
her dive is it Craig from dream dad yeah
oh my god it is it is legitimately a
type I know I don't find most people
interesting yeah okay that's not that's
not gonna work because she like loves
validation she loves that she doesn't
need it but she have to have a guy
that's like gonna be excited about her
yeah I mean if she just wants to like
kiss a cute guy that looks like that guy
in the video game but she likes yeah
well you found a good just like shave
the whole thing out of his Oh he'd be a
perfect fit next is Joseph Oh peg love a
J name
I mean he's fine see that's the thing
everyone in LA
fine uh no you don't you don't just want
to find God last um Blake he works with
us series and I'm web scout
he'd be a great fit he would Kelsey yes
southern charm Oh his southern I don't
know Hank about him I just see him
walking around out of like yeah I mean
he's tall so you know automatically the
tall girls really love at all we love at
all we love at all yeah I love a man I
feel like it's not that Kelsey's
intimidating but Kelsey is such like an
actress in like a high energy that'll
picture her with someone they think it
needs to be like the same kind of
caliber of like siete mm-hmm and I think
what Kelsey really needs is someone
who's like not that and it's more
down-to-earth and kind of like to
balance out her energy so I think that's
why I picked like because he's very he's
a way comment yeah and I think ten if
she wants like hype energy I think ten
will give that to her okay so um I guess
we've decided I think Taryn and Kelsey
could have a lot of thoughts yeah he
looks like an interesting man with lots
of stories to tell yeah second choice
I'll let you pick honestly I think it
has to be Blake okay he looks so cozy
yeah I'm beat yeah like a bunny chill
guy yeah honestly I think would do
Kelsey good so now we're gonna text
Blake woo I'd be like hey Blake let's
play games and hang out cuz you're cool
and I feel like she would say a lot of
words and between that because I feel
like should we get nervous she would
overthink this text more than either of
us are we're not even thinking and now
we're not
hey Blake let's play some games and
chill monkey emoji covering monkey emoji
and now we're gonna text um Taryn oh
Kelsey
obviously she likes to be like playfully
competitive yeah so she taunts to be
like oh is that just 40 pounds you were
benching in the gym
mm I'd love to show you how it's really
done Oh perfect
okay so I mean Kelsey's gonna go on some
dates and she tells me she enjoys hey
what's going on I'm Blake I'm 30 years
old I'm a video editor and today I'm
bringing Kelsey to two bit circus yeah I
think this would be a cool day for her
there's a lot of different games to play
I see around the office a lot to be
honest with you if she's like she's very
successful and very driven and smart but
also like really really pretty so it's
like she's got a bit of an intimidating
factor to her whenever you're walking
around the office you're like but I just
hope that you know let's just a can
spark a second day third day fourth date
either way let's get it going
okay I just arrived at ooh big circus
and I'm walking up to have my own ate
with Blake I'm a little nervous
obviously Trey was a really cool spot so
excited to go I'm Kelsey nice to meet
you
oh you too are you a hugger so you ready
to play some games I figured this with
you this is yeah this is accurate I'm
gonna be ready too bad though okay I'll
go easy on you let's do it that's what's
your favorite thing
super vlogging a first date yeah all
right you ready for some VR yeah let's
get virtual
[Music]
shot at love
be our world right now oh gosh
[Music]
all right like I challenge you to some
ski ball nobody I'm good at I'm pretty
good so we're halfway through this right
now I think it's going well I think that
if I had to guess I think I've like done
enough to like get a second date but
she's still just kind of like ah he's
okay I think she's awesome
I think she's cute she's got a beautiful
smile it's made it's really smart she's
great at these video games it's cool I
love that she like took it down to one
knee during the VR things they just
showed like a real commitment let's just
see how the rest of this goes hopefully
she doesn't think I'm a complete idiot
she's a monster
she's destroying buildings it's like the
cutest version of Donkey Kong you've
ever seen okay it's been really fun it's
an awesome place that he took me to
theaters really fun he seems like a
really good sport for the second half
I'm hoping to kind of just just to enjoy
myself and have a good time and get to
know Blake
you brought me enough to play a bunch of
video games it's not to like you know
okay so there's this one game that I've
always wanted to play here it's called
beat saver have you heard of it no okay
it's like it's like music and like it's
like you're a Jedi it looks like
lightsabers yeah I think she's going a
little power crazy you know
oh we just finished our date she just
left gave a nice little hug goodbye
first date you know I think it went
pretty well she's a really cool girl
she's she's super smart and funny and
she's great at video games which I love
I know she has to go on date with
another guy
he could be Prince Charming and I could
end up just being a guy that took her to
two bit circus once so let's just see
how it all turns out what's up guys I'm
- Ron I'm 27 years old we are at City of
Angels boxing for the date to the twitch
streamer just like me
and coming here to the boxing ring just
to see how she can move and he may even
talk about a little bit of game so I
think I'm the perfect match all right
let's get into this date I'm excited I
know I can win Kelsey over I am on my
way to my second date I'm a little
nervous I think I got into my head a lot
in the first date best-case scenario I
meet the love of my life worst-case
scenario I take a workout class with a
person that I don't have to hang out
without for that so I have a good time I
mean I snore you talk to the workout I
came to bring you here for business
[Music]
it's actually really fun it's definitely
I was nervous at first but once you
start getting boxed and you kind of got
out of your head get to know another
side of here being when you see him go
to town on a on a bag I mean it's like
undeniable that he's a very attractive
human being uh also he's super funny in
between all the boxing we get to talk
about gaming nerd culture you know he
asked me about Star Wars which is
definitely a big a big one for me and so
I'm having a really good time so we'll
see there's a time when we had to box
the same bag and through that I felt the
punch connection the electricity was
going through the bag and I was just
feeling like oh yeah this is it
and we're just here talking about some
gaming and stuff as well everything is
going exactly as I planned
boxing training on our first date
tonight that's something out of the zone
you wouldn't think something like this
will work I'm definitely buying to
become the winner of this little battle
I got with whoever else
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right God all jokes aside like
shakes beautiful I really hope that I
get this day and I'm feeling confident
about the date that we had today so with
that being said I mean like yo he worked
out together we talked about gaming
together that's a perfect life yo
staying in shape healthy and doing what
we love most which is Star Wars they're
both people and I mean didn't work for
fun
so how was Blake Blake was great he took
me to an arcade bar which was like not
really perfect for ya choice for me we
had so much fun he really liked let let
go and was like easygoing one thing what
he did but he was obviously this other
gentleman you know she was definitely
trying to be a charmer someone going for
that charm okay so he's laying down the
moat a little bit a little bit he put
his arm around me I was like okay
awesome and how was Taryn Terrell it was
really great you know at first I was
kind of like anxious yeah then he was
just immediately so warm and like really
easy to talk to and get along with and I
think the activity although surprising I
don't think I would normally pick a
boxing class versus yeah being a really
good idea because like moving together
and it like really just like you
wouldn't really focus on worrying about
the date oh that's cool I really love
how these guys were very you know how
can I say thoughtful when picking out
the dates very thoughtful yeah be really
put into their homework okay so tell me
about the highs and lows of the date
look like I think the high was
definitely like all the activities we
had really like a lot of fun like
playing beat Sabre and doing you know
being on different
and kind of like calling each other out
I think a lo would be that I think I
might have been in my head quite a bit
during it I think I was like trying to
have fun but it was like kind of awkward
for me to be on camera so the second
date was like I already kind of knew
what I was covered yeah so that the hi
was like kind of like breaking down that
barrier for me and was like having a
good time in getting to know another
person I think the high was like he was
just like really fun and be like really
vibe dat one whole of our interests you
know was like anime and gaming and
twitch and like in Fitness below I think
was like it was hard to communicate
because we were in a boxing yeah so it's
time for the big question who would you
want a second date with you know I think
if Taryn were to ask me I'd consider it
for sure i'ma get that day I think we
really gelled but I think overall the
thing I really learned is that I think
I'm ready to date again mmm
which I think like was the thing I
wasn't expecting from this experience
now I'm like open to to like see if
maybe 20 choices here for a lot for me
yeah though the [ __ ] about opening
yourself up to having a boat you don't
need to find a blue in the show as long
as you know that you're worth love and
appreciation then I've done my job
buildable their choice
I can find my friends
[Music]